shout out to Def Jam man we got filthy
rich in the building what's good Kev how
you doing how are you doing y'all here
rap hustling as you like to call it yeah
rap hustling man getting on the road
getting to a bag so when you come to
like obviously you have a hosting
tonight in town but when you come to AZ
for a weekend like Super Bowl yeah
what is like the target like how many
verses you plan on recording this
weekend this [__] I don't know who's
gonna be out here uh I know you know
it's going to be packed so see me what I
see like I don't like me I could just
get on the road and just go somewhere
right and just post it just post up post
it on online
hit me for features shows right whatever
and they're gonna tap in videos that's
just something I built I kind of learned
that from Jack right yeah I'm saying
like he used to tell me that back in the
day like just come it's gonna be good
you might you might not you never know
what you might run into like you might
run into a promoter that I've been
trying to book you I didn't have no
contact right somebody want to get a
verse from you um
[__] whatever we might it might want to
pay you to come to a meet and greet like
I I you know I come from the era just
really like you know the independent
grind yeah I'm saying so it's kind of
easy would you pay for a feature in a
weekend like this if you run into the
right artist and they're like yo what's
up let's work let's do this right now
yeah no I ain't paying anything you
ain't paying nobody for a future no not
at this point like back in the day when
I first started rapping right you know
what I'm saying but I know everybody who
who's the most expensive feature you
ever had to pay for back in the day when
you all the features was the same price
which is what it was a dime ten bands
yeah okay I ain't never pay no more than
that that's not bad yeah it comes with
the video this is like my early yeah
early on what year are we thinking when
I first started rapping just ran into
[__] and not no having no relationship
let me cash you out they have no problem
it wasn't even like that it's just like
oh man what's up like I'm trying to get
you on my on my phone yeah I know what
it is again I'm saying right I don't
know him he'll know me and it's just
like the same thing for me right
I mean I can't be biased about it you
know man people don't bought features
for me so if Jay-Z you running hope
Hope's like yo I got you just I need 25
bands you better do that for your Jay-Z
feature yeah listen that's that's
unbelievable run to the bank you don't
gotta run the bank but that's
unbelievable well frontier people it's
gonna cost more than that to clear that
dad for sure that's impossible so a
hundred percent you know I'm just I'm
putting out uh I mean I'm looking at it
like 25 000 is not a lot for Jay-Z so
it's like I feel like if he'd do it for
that he'll just do it for free if he
seen my if he seen my talent my work
ethic and like you know what I'm saying
like like a lot of people hit me up I
tell them my price so it's like people
to hit me up before and be like okay
I cannot give you this and I'm like nah
right and I'm like hey if I'm gonna do
it for that might as well just do it
free